what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have
forced my sister to come on the show
with me
in what we call an emergency this is a
manosphere emergency
okay can you could you act excited
could you act a little excited
you don't want to be here okay okay
so let's oh no let me let me make us a
little bigger guys
can you hear me okay by the way i know i
have audio issues sometimes so i just
try to like
you know
oh let's make this bigger okay
so
today we are talking about jada
and will
now what do you know about jada and will
eva
literally nothing i don't follow anyone
like that
okay so
did you know jada and will used to be
like the power couple like were you
aware of that no i always thought it was
like
j-lo
j-lo
no not jayla what is it
never mind uh
oh
are you okay
sorry
there's only so much these chords can go
we should have stayed over there i don't
know what i was doing
so
okay i'm going to just give you like an
overview so jada and will
together right and people growing up
always thought they were the power
couple
so like there was always quotes about
jada like hold on
let me find it
okay i can't there's just always quotes
about like will saying like people leave
stop people come on come on like people
leave too soon and like marriages that
make sense
hold your mic hold your mag put it by
you
so
because i'm gonna go like this let's see
can they still see you yeah they can
do we freeze
why
oh my god
hold on
not your best look there hannah oh
oh my god why
why is it not it says it's going here oh
my god
is it is it working on the screen or is
it frozen
the audio's working
lord lord have mercy
it's like
why
like i don't even know what the deal is
because it's showing that it's working
on here the audio's working
all right hold on guys we're gonna
technical difficulties i'm sorry guys
we're gonna end it and try again oh wait
is it working
you removing that it can show
like it's showing
that being removed yeah i know but it's
not
[Music]
okay guys we're gonna have to
i'm gonna restart my computer and try
this again hold on